here congratulations on the canadian
launch what does this mean to you
tonight it means everything we are now
officially
launched key soul care which is my
lifestyle and beauty but really about
focusing on how do we create
ritual out of routine and so we just
launched in sephora canada bang and
we're here celebrating that which to me
feels so perfect
my connection with canada is very pure
every time i've come here it's like i
keeps threatening i'm like i'm moving to
canada we will take everyone feels like
we're moving to canada so the vibe is
magnificent the support is beautiful the
love is real i'm so glad that we're here
you can definitely feel the energy in
the room you know when it comes to your
beauty standards what does beauty mean
to you
beauty to me means how you represent
how you feel on any particular day
because there's days that i feel really
beautiful in my sweatpants my my jordans
my you know a little tank top and and
that's perfect my hair like in a puffy
bun
and there's days when i want to turn up
a little bit more and get a little bit
more like what we call full wattage and
kind of go and but i feel beautiful as
myself and that's what key soul care is
all about we're not talking about being
someone that you aren't we're talking
about
nurturing who you actually are what i
find so adorable is that uh when it
comes to some of your offerings yes
swizz seems to love it
let me first of all let me tell you
keith so care is for everyone i know a
lot of times people feel that in the
beauty space it's more for women or
feminine energies but it is for everyone
and so my husband swiss he loves it i
give him facials i put all the serums on
i wash his face and he you know i think
a lot of times people don't pay
attention to how good that feels he's
loving it he's totally turned on
hey the videos are so adorable i want
more
we have to do another one he's gonna be
like okay let's do it
people are raving about girl on fire
what's it like for you getting such
positive feedback from so many young
readers you know what this i have to say
is a really important thing i just
released of my first graphic novel
called girl on fire it's amazing it's so
good about a young woman growing up in
brooklyn named lolo wright who her
brother is actually racially profiled by
police officers and she is so angry and
wants to protect him she discovers these
powers that she has it's definitely a
metaphor for the powers that we all have
because we all have a superpower that's
special to us and so to have young
readers
integrating into a song that to me is
one of the most special important songs
i've ever written
is is it gives it a whole other life and
i'm so proud of that and it's it gives
an interpretation to a song that maybe
you didn't have before it's like your
kids are a big fan too they love it my
oldest he's egypt he's 11. he's like
mommy let me read you the part and he's
like reading me the book i'm loving it's
such a great way to engage because if
you don't exactly want to read a novel
it's still a novel length but you get a
chance to have the pictures it's
illustrated by britney howard a
beautiful black illustrator woman it is
so wonderful thank you for um bringing
it up that's amazing you know it's been
over 20 years since your debut album
which is wild does that feel wild to you
yes
you know if you could go back in time
and do it all over again would you do it
all the same
[Applause]
yes because it all brought me to here
but
if there's anything that i would have
would do differently
i think i wouldn't
take so long
to realize that some people weren't
meant for me
and i would have kind of called that
quicker and moved on quicker and not
felt you know worried that that would
somehow affect something because i
realized that although people support us
in our journey
you
make your journey
and
that one so that would be the only thing
listen you have so many women here
tonight you are a role model you are
like the pinnacle of success for so many
artists and and young women
you know what kind of advice do you have
for somebody who looks at you and wants
to follow in your footsteps
you know what i would say is
that
one thing sometimes maybe i also would
like to
rethink is that i would compare myself
to other people and i would feel like
maybe i would feel disappointed that i
didn't have what they had or have you
know the certain whatever it is that
we're all looking for but i realized
that i felt that way because there was
something about that that i wanted to
cultivate in myself so i started to use
that as more of motivation
to in my way though in my way so i would
just say you are your own unique special
one of one and there's really nobody
like me like you like you and we get to
own that and so just keep
going the worst thing you can do is stop
because if you stop then
that's what you did but if you keep
going you will find your path you will
find the direction that's right for you
and trust your gut when your gut says go
that way
go
when you're when your gut says that
person's not right
no trust it so that's what i would say
it's true we do not trust our gut enough
and it's so well because it's so strong
and just to wrap things up you know i
know that you have such a musical home i
mean you are recording you're writing at
home if your kids wanted to make music a
career and they wanted to kind of live
in that public eye as a performer would
you be on board for that listen if
if they are
up for it
then i think that's beautiful because we
do need music music is such a it's a
religion it's a it's a spiritual
experience you know in so many ways it's
a communication so i do believe when
you're doing anything for the right
reasons because you actually love it and
because it brings you and other people
something powerful
you have to follow it and so if they
told me this is what i love i would
encourage it and i would of course also
have some insight
as to some of the pitfalls and i'd be
grateful that i can hopefully guide them
you know to avoid them but i would
celebrate that this is their love
listen i've only talked to you for like
seven minutes but i feel inspired you've
given great advice so so lovely getting
to meet you oh my gosh i love talking to
you i'm so happy